there's something about me uh that is
incredibly attracted to the notion of
something that on the surface sounds
very very simple
but under the covers is actually rather
complicated is it actually extremely
complicated and that was was like my
kryptonite that was like okay
or my intro drug as it were i needed
more of that this notion of something
being inherently simple but also complex
that's what kind of got me really
excited about being in the data and
analytics space about being in the
governance space
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is all about data management and
data governance
meet malcolm a thought leader in the
field of master data management and data
governance and has consulted with some
of the most largest businesses in the
world on their enterprise information
management strategies
he is a frequent public speaker on data
and analytics best practices and
cherishes the opportunity to share
practical and actionable insights on how
companies can achieve their strategic
imperatives by improving their approach
to data management
this world is changing so quickly and
data is becoming probably the most
important asset for for any company and
your expertise is in data and and
data governance today you're the head of
data strategy at prophecy previously
senior director analyst at ed gardner
amongst many other really interesting
positions and so a lot to talk about
here a lot to unpack and and what i'd
love to spend these 20 minutes is to
understand a little bit better
you know your own journey and and data
governance
as a as a domain that we should be
really thinking critically about both as
entrepreneurs as engineers and as
thinkers in general so thank you very
much for being here
thank you so much well my my data origin
story i think is is what what you're
what you're asking
and uh
i've been in the software space for the
better part of 30 years it sounds
amazing to say that
um but it's true
uh i've been in the software space an
awfully long time but i really kind of
fell down the data and analytics and the
data governance rabbit hole uh about 20
years ago just about 20 years ago when i
was a consultant and i got hired by a
two billion dollar publicly traded
company
as a consultant to hot to answer one
question
that question was how many customers do
we have
and i was at the time i was wait a
minute hold on a second
your publicly traded company you're
relatively large company you have uh
audited books every quarterly from from
some large consulting company and and
and you're reporting to the street what
do you mean you don't know how many
customers you have
and when i dove into that issue and when
i dove into that problem what i learned
was that was that
that was very much an actual real
problem in that the system that they
were using the company was using to
report revenue and count dollars that
had a consistent answer all the time and
it was the system of truth at least in
so far as wall street was concerned but
there were other systems across the
organization that completely different
answers
so the erp system that was counting the
dollars had 100 customers in it i don't
know let's just say 100 customers and
the crm systems had
140 and another system over here had 25
and another system over here had an
totally different number so there was no
consistent definition of of customer
there was no consistent customer
reporting within this organization
and and that again that was really my
intro to to data governance data
analytics master data management and
there's something about me uh that is
incredibly attracted to the notion of
something that on the surface sounds
very very simple
but under the covers is actually rather
complicated is it actually extremely
complicated and that was was was like my
kryptonite that was like okay
or my intro drug as it were i needed
more of that this notion of something
being inherently simple but also complex
that's what kind of got me really
excited about being in the data and
analytics space about being in the
governance space
on the surface governance is a fairly
boring topic as
it were not a lot of people are having
cocktail party discussions about
governance but
a lot of people are having conversations
about customers and customer data and
their experience with products and what
worked with one one company what didn't
work with another company these things
always come back to data
right so they always come back to data
so so yes governance is critical
discussions around data management are
critical
you know there are companies talking
about data as the new oil can certainly
discuss that a little bit more but
that's a little bit about how i got into
the space
so what what are sort of the
the the dangers perhaps or
the ramifications of not doing good
governance i mean obviously okay so
discrepancies lack of source of truth
and
that that makes sense but why why should
we really care
yeah well it depends on your industry
but if you're in banking or your
insurance you really need to care about
data governance right things you know we
hear all the time about high profile
data breaches about personal information
that gets spread across the internet i
mean those are fairly dire and extreme
uh examples of lacks a lack of
governance
um
certainly you know just to make sure
that you comply with the with the laws
and regulatory frameworks i mean is is
for a lot of banks and insurance
companies and other regulated industries
is the kind of the lowest bar from a
governance perspective you have to be
there otherwise that your entire
business could potentially be at risk
but a lot of companies these days are
talking about digital transformation a
lot of companies are talking about how
to respond faster to ever-changing
business dynamics a lot of companies are
talking about how to realize and deal
with changes related to what's going on
in our global supply chains
all of these things come right back to
data right if you're talking about a
digital transformation chances are
pretty good
your customer experience is an important
part of that
well how do you deliver a compelling
customer experience if you don't know
how many customers you have or if you
have two records for the same customer
right or if your customer calls into
your support center and you don't know
who that customer is and you don't know
their past history with you right same
is true from a supplier perspective how
are you expected to optimize your supply
chain if you don't necessarily know who
your suppliers are if you don't have a
complete you know 360 view
of your relationship with a given
supplier so everything from
from a digital transformation
perspective a supply chain optimization
perspective a business optimization
perspective will circle right back to
data and if you don't have consistent
trustworthy accurate data you're going
to you're going to struggle to optimize
all of those business processes that i
was just talking about
and is it mainly this idea of source of
truth is that sort of the the holy grail
of data governance or are there
different aspects that we need to be
considerate of
it it's a part of it but it's certainly
not the only thing so there are a number
of various what they call frameworks out
there from for data governance data
governance spans yes a single source of
truth it spans into data quality it
spans into data access who can see what
data it spans into ownership of data
update rights those types of things it
even gets into things like archival how
long do you need to keep data around so
security pii
all these things together form uh data
governance so it's not just about having
a single source of truth but that's a
big part of it right single source of
truth is generally the domain of what we
call master data management mdm which is
one of the the kind of the operating
tenants of the data governance framework
mdm acknowledges that really can not all
data is created equally there are some
fields of data some objects of data like
customer product supplier asset
employee on and on that are that matter
more than other pieces of data right so
in any given customer record you could
have hundreds of fields of data but the
data that is shared widely across the
organization that needs consistent
definition that needs consistent quality
and management and structure that's
generally what we call mdm master data
management uh
and and that's again a sub
sub component of governance but
uh it's all together critically
important for organizations to scale for
organizations to meet their customer
needs for organizations to to operate in
in a way in today's days and times it
keeps them ahead of their competition
so if we're looking at the world today
you know 2022 and the way that companies
are managing this what are some
different strategies that companies are
employing
that are that are that are good you know
good strategies for
for doing good data governance around us
yeah
it's a great question and i'll be honest
michael and say you know given my
years of experience as an analyst in the
in the governance space i can say it
remains a massive challenge for more so
most organizations right most
organizations are really really kind of
struggling with
two various different two approaches at
a very very high level decentralized
versus centralized
right do you do you manage your data
from more of a centralized approach more
of a top-down heavy-handed approach to
say
these are our customers there's a single
customer table that needs to be
referenced by all applications all
systems all workflows do you have
centralized approaches to data
management or do you have highly
decentralized approaches to data
management where you can have autonomy
within an individual operating unit or
application or group or business process
and those are two extreme ends of the
spectrum most of the organizations that
i that i've supported over the last few
years are trying to act in a highly
decentralized way with some notion of
centralization layered over top again so
that at an individual operating unit or
application you can have a decent amount
of autonomy where sales can call a
customer what sales needs to call a
customer but finance can call a customer
something slightly different
one is how you sell the other is how you
recognize revenue but at some levels
within the organization when you move up
the organization for more of an
enterprise wide v view or corporate wide
view some of those rules need to be
consistent because again if your ceo
asks how many customers do we have there
can really only be one answer so what is
this this this sweet spot for most
organization is a hybrid between highly
decentralized do whatever you want
and highly centralized completely kind
of top-down kind of edict-driven
approaches to governance generally it's
some hybrid in the middle of those two
approaches right so what i'm hearing
from you is like the word we're looking
for is this balance where you're both
giving agency to
to the different
you know agents within the organization
to to work with data collect data and
manage it but then there should be some
governance as to
what types of data do we need
centralized and to have a source of
truth where everybody's aligned on sort
of the same answer right
exactly exactly right and typically
again that aligns more towards this
notion of of master data right where you
do need some commonality
in order to have uh you know consistent
views of consistent ways of managing
your relationships with your suppliers
or your relationships with your
customers and on and on so so
yeah the sweet part is is is some sort
of of hybrid approach there and i love
the notion of kind of decentralized
agency uh of data
but what you would just describe does
infer a certain degree of maturity from
a governance perspective because to do
what we just described requires a
reasonable set of business rules that
says
a bunch of if thens in essence you know
if it's this data in this context and
this use case then these are the rules
and if it's a different set of data if
it's if it's master data then these are
the set of rules and and really that's
what governance is data governance are
the policies and procedures that need to
be applied to an organization's data
assets in order to realize the greatest
value from them
right and and so
up to what level or down to our level
should should people in their
organization care about this or be
concerned with this right i mean is this
something that should be
in the mind of of all the way down to
the you know to the back end engineers
is this mainly the data analytics side
the vp stage
where where are we on the spectrum of of
an organization
that's that's a great question and the
answer is it depends
right if if you are a software engineer
you need to care about data because
those are the fields that you're using
to create your application right if
you're a ceo you need to be caring about
data now the perspective there is going
to be very very different but
a very effective data governance
approach is one that makes the rules
that makes the data relevant for where
you are where you sit within the
organization
now really effective data governance
organizations can can do this in a
non-obtrusive way right where where
where data governance and data quality
and policies and procedures related to
the use of data are just kind of baked
in to how you do your job it's it's part
of the standard operating procedure this
is kind of
the notion of what we call data ops
right where where you know that data and
data policies and data governance are
just kind of hardwired into how you do
your business day in and day out and
very very good ones and high functioning
organizations can make it such that it
doesn't appear like it is all uh it's
all rules like it's all constraints
right a high functioning organization
can put governance policies into for
example a crm system so that if a
salesperson is interacting in there and
creating a new customer record
that the the controls that are put into
place are actually helpful
right
they they they make sure that you don't
put in duplicate accounts they make sure
that you are
aligning that account to the right or to
that to that customer to the right
account and so that rev rec can be
correctly applied so it really depends
on the level of the organization
everybody will have different views but
when done the right way governance
should be viewed as an enabler
of business and not as some form of
control of the business and and that's
what that's what organ high functioning
organizations are trying to get to is
this notion again of
governance is something that makes
things better and not a way of slowing
organizations down
so we talked a little bit about
centralization versus decentralization
within organizations
but now for looking at data governance
is sort of a strategy and different ways
to
or different best practices to implement
data governance are we seeing a new
vertical of
outside organizations that are mastering
this in some sas product or some
strategic way to then be able to go and
integrate into organizations how were we
at in terms of the industry
and the opportunities for data
governance in the world
it's a it's a great question the short
answer is there are lots of fanta
fantastic technologies that can be sold
to sas
that can help automate a lot of data
management tasks including data
governance so data governance spans all
the way from data cataloging like
knowing what you've got out there data
profiling you know where are all the
fields of data and and how are they
defined and what's all the metadata
associated to them so there's there's
gonna
that's one aspect of data governance and
then the other aspect of it is
management of policies and procedures
third aspect is execution of those
policies and procedures making sure that
they're actually enforced there are
great solutions that are out there in
the market that do all of those things
but they're highly dependent on humans
defining business rules for data
management
what's acceptable what's not acceptable
even things like
something called entity resolution
matching
joe smith joseph smith is that one thing
or is that two things
generally historically at the very least
the technology solutions in this space
have allowed him or who have required
human beings to define those rules now
we are seeing a pivot in this space with
the application of newer technologies to
allow for audit added layers of of
automation uh uh in data management and
so where you can see some use of ai and
ml to start automating some of these
decisions
where you could in theory use
ai to look at large swaths of data to
understand when data is being used
correctly versus when data is being used
incorrectly based on things like was
that was that transaction successful or
was it not successful if it was
successful that's indicated of of good
data if it's not then that maybe
indicates bad data it's a very very high
level example of how ai could be applied
uh to help kind of what we call augment
uh some of the data management decisions
so we are in the middle of a pivot uh
with it within the software world away
from truly human driven this gets into
even things like data modeling like just
relying on humans to build data models
yeah where you can actually start to
rely more and more in algorithms to
define the data models another great
example is graph
graph is being level leveraged heavily
within the data management space because
it's really good at showing
relationships
right so relation hierarchies uh
ontologies are are are intrinsic to data
management right how do things relate to
each other how do corporate entities
relate to each other that's a perfect
use case for a graph type application to
go in and say ah here's how your data is
all related to each other and we can
actually maybe even take a first pass at
some sort of a hierarchy here of a way
of organizing your data that makes
logical sense that doesn't rely on a
human being trying to figure it all out
so there's a pivot
going on in this space a lot of the
software solutions are moving towards
more of these ai and ml driven
infrastructures but they'll never truly
automate uh the human factor here never
truly get away from that so there will
always be a role for some degree of
human oversight when it comes to uh uh
data management
right it sounds like it all it also
speaks a little bit to the trend of
supervised versus unsupervised learning
from ai models this understanding that
you know some things we can
you know um
yep we can dictate the question or we
can dictate sort of a a requested
response
and through supervised data but but if
we're looking at unstructured data that
we may not even we may be humble and say
you know what we're not actually sure
that we understand this data as well as
we should maybe we should maybe we
should leverage some algorithms to help
us identify how we should be even
interpreting this data so i think that
that that speaks a lot to that and um i
i think you know we're we're running out
of time but this is a fascinating
conversation what i really also want to
get at is you know why are you so
excited about this so why why are you
you know why are you spending your time
talking about data governance and
mastery of data why is it something that
you're personally excited about
i i'm on a mission to make this easier
for companies i i really really am i'm
excited about it again getting back to
what i was talking about before it seems
simple but it's actually not and i've
applied more than a decade of thought
into this space and it's my mission to
try to help people understand this and
to help companies overcome a lot of
these things
i it's a sad truth that companies still
struggle with with data governance with
master data management but there are
things that work there are things that
we know work for example if you focus
more on business outcomes
instead of focusing on data quality i
will i use when i was an analyst i used
to ask all the time you know how will
you know will you you succeeded how will
you know when you fixed things from a
data management perspective and i would
hear people say all the time well our
data will be better well nobody cares
about that people care about business
outcomes people care about more money
lower costs or less risk right that's
just one example of an approach that we
know
works so over the years through the
school of hard knocks i've come to know
what works and what doesn't work and i
want to share that with as many
companies and with many people as i can
because when we do we know it can drive
incredible value for organizations
incredible and malcolm i really want to
thank you for taking this time and
spending it with me talking about data
governance data mastery you know the
motivations the the the journey that we
run and and a little bit about you know
how we should be giving respect to this
world and to to the importance of it so
thank you very very much continue making
a great impact on our
organizations and best of luck
thanks so much michael really
appreciated our time today thanks thank
you
[Music]